herzlich willkommen zu meinem heutigen
video leute ich sitze gerade in einem
szenario dass hier wahrscheinlich kennt
ich dachte mir nicht ich nehme heute
einfach mal in meinem wohnzimmer auch
und noch eine sache ist komisch dass
checkt hier wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht
aber wir haben 23 uhr und ich weiß nicht
wann ich zuletzt so spät denn an
künstlerischen videoaufnahme ab weil ich
meine videos eigentlich immer tagsüber
drehen aber das tut auch überhaupt
nichts zur sache gut dass ich gesagt
habe ich habe auf meinem instagram
account hier habt ihr mal meinen
instagram namen eingeblendet bitte folgt
mehr nach gerüchten über mich gefragt
ihr habt das vielleicht mitbekommen das
ist so ein kleiner trend auf youtube in
letzter zeit luca das gemacht müsstest
beraters gemacht nike macht es jetzt
auch und viele leute haben das einfach
schon gemacht ich hab halt nach
gerüchten über mich gefragt weil ich war
mir relativ sicher dass es bestimmt
einige gerüchte über mich gibt und ich
wurde nicht enttäuscht das sind
zahlreiche einsendungen auf meinem
instagram account gekommen und ich werde
euch jetzt mal ein paar aussuchen
erstmal ein super viele leute dich
einfach so kenne freunde aus der uni
oder auch wieso geschrieben
das gericht sei dass ich einen kleinen
habe dankeschön an der stelle
dieses gericht ist natürlich nicht der
wahrheit entsprechend aber es gab auch
wirklich interessante gerüchte und ihr
werdet euch sicherlich oder vielleicht
auch schon die eine oder andere sache
mal gefragt haben das gerücht nummer
eins und das interessiert glaube ich
wirklich super viele leute ist dass ich
angeblich streit mit luca hatte und ich
lese das wirklich mega häufig und ich
antworte eigentlich auch oft darauf und
sagt nein hatten wir nicht also es gab
nie irgendwie ein vorteil bei mir in
kluger der dazu geführt hat dass wir uns
hassen oder sonst irgendwas wie das halt
einfach manchmal so ist haben wir uns so
ein bisschen kann auch komisch sich
dafür rechtfertigen zu müssen aber wir
haben uns ein bisschen auseinander
gelebt so aber es gab auf jeden fall nie
irgendwie einen krassen streit oder
sonst irgendwas was dazu geführt hätte
dass wir gesagt
so haben wir nie wieder was miteinander
zu tun hier ist einfach nicht so aber
ohne viele leute glauben dass das war
vielleicht die erste wenn ich die zweite
meiste sache die kamen bei den größten
über mich es stimmt aber nicht
es hat tatsächlich auch ein paar leute
geschrieben dass ich mal was mit luca
hatte wegen diesen maus shipping auch
das ist nicht der wahrheit entsprechen
auch wenn das vielleicht jetzt alte
wunden aufgerissen werden von manchen
maus schiffern super viele leute auf
gefragt du bist eigentlich schwul und
ich verstehe das nicht so ganz warum
sollte ich keine ahnung über jahre
hinweg eine beziehung führen die auch
zum teil öffentlich war auf youtube und
eigentlich schwul sein macht nicht so
viel sehen und dementsprechend jetzt
auch leider dieses gericht nicht der
wahrheit entsprechend in die gleiche
richtung geht auch das folgende gerücht
mir kam schon mal vor dass du bisexuell
ist auch das stimmt einfach nicht und
ich weiß nicht warum so viele leute das
denken ich meine wie kommt man auf den
gedanken also ich stehe auf frauen es
nur auf frauen und nicht auf männer und
nicht auf beides ist einfach so kann
wenn ihr eine idee habt wie die leute
darauf kommen dann schreibt man die
kommentare viele leute das nächste ist
wahrscheinlich die sache wie ich
mindestens so ich gelesen habe dass ich
mit luca streit hatte dass jana und ich
eine freundschaft plus haben nachdem wir
uns jetzt getrennt haben dazu kann ich
nur sagen dass auch das nicht stimmt
irgendwie war es ja noch kein gericht
dabei etwas gestimmt hat glaube ich über
mich aber ich glaube das haben gerichte
oft so an sich dass sie so erzählt
werden und sich stimme einfach nicht
also super viele leute glauben weil ja
und ich uns getrennt haben auch
öffentlich und was gesagt haben und so
weiter und so fort
aber weil wir uns jetzt noch sehen dass
wir irgendwie eine freundschaft plus
haben keine ahnung also ich glaube wir
würden uns wahrscheinlich nicht mehr so
gut verstehen und so was hätten wir das
nicht so konsequent gehalten unsere
trennung und hätten nicht gesagt okay
heute sind wir getrennt und punkt ich
glaube generell haben wir das halt
wirklich mega gesund
8 wie wir uns getrennt haben und deshalb
ist es uns auch möglich dass jetzt
einfach befreundet sind ohne halt
irgendwie noch was miteinander zu haben
fällt wahrscheinlich viele leute schwer
das zu glauben wahrscheinlich denkt sich
dann so jeder seinen teil die chill noch
zusammen aber es ist wirklich so
wir sind einfach befreundet jetzt und es
funktioniert tatsächlich
unglaublicherweise wir haben keine
freundschaft plus
alternativ habe ich auch schon öfter
gelesen und jana seid immer noch
zusammen also unsere trennung oder fake
aber wir sind noch zusammen läuft
wahrscheinlich so mehr oder weniger aufs
gleiche raus aber auch das stimmt nicht
wenn wir haben tatsächlich einfach nur
die wahrheit gesagt und sind nicht
zusammen aber bevor auch hier gelesen
jana hatte ich eigentlich bedrohungen 1
auch keiner von uns hat den anderen
betrogen sondern haben uns wirklich
einfach so wie jetzt erzählte guten
getrennt und ich bin auch sehr froh
darüber
aber wir schon wieder lust hat mich
weiter mit jana zusammen nächstes
gericht über mich dass ich nicht
abgeneigt sei etwas mit einem fan
anzufangen und keine ahnung woher das
kommt ich hatte wirklich in meinem leben
noch nie war es mit einem fan also dass
die situation hat sich gar nicht ergeben
und das klingt ja so als sei es so ein
gerücht dass leute über mich denken dass
ich öfters mit fans haare
dazu kann ich nur sagen nein das stimmt
nicht auch wieder interessant wie die
leute darauf kommen dass zu erzählen
generell so diese ganze gerüchte welt
ist mir eigentlich übertrieben fremd
also im prinzip war es so eigentlich als
ich meine kennengelernt habe grüße gehen
raus an maike an dieser stelle
das war wirklich neu für mich dass leute
so gerüchte über einander erzählen und
keine ahnung irgendwie hatte ich damit
nie so wirklich kontaktpunkte aber
das ist tatsächlich echt eine sache die
leute gerne machen ich kann auch
verstehen ist es auch interessant so
wenn man so erzählt bekommt der hat das
gemacht und dann kann man sich darüber
austauschen und so aber das war wirklich
neu für mich und scheinbar gibt es auch
jede menge gerüchte über mich und bisher
habe keines gestimmt ist es auch
wirklich nicht so als würde ich jetzt
irgendwelche sachen auslassen oder sowas
sondern das sind einfach die meisten
sachen die ein geschickt wurden und
bisher hat wirklich einfach nichts
gestimmt
bei mir sagen viele in der klasse dass
du mal mit luca zusammen warst also
stimmt halt einfach nicht und das liegt
halt an diesem maus shipping so und die
leute haben das ein bisschen weit
gedacht sage ich mal ein weiteres
gerücht ist dass wir bastian jetzt mit
mir in meiner wohnung wohnt also wie ihr
vielleicht wisst habe ich mich ja hier
in der wohnung gewohnt und das gerücht
ist gar nicht so weit hergeholt weil
wenn man sich sebastians videos mal
anschaut sind die eigentlich immer in
meiner wohnung aufgenommen
das liegt aber nicht daran dass
sebastian ihr wohnt sondern sebastian
wohnt direkt neben mir quasi also der
hat eine wohnung die ist 30 meter also
so was von meiner wohnung weg und wir
sind quasi nachbarn und dadurch weniger
hat den ganzen tag zusammen bei mir in
der wohnung weil meine wohnung zeit ein
bisschen mehr eingerichtet was ja wohl
noch nicht so lange in einer anderen
wohnung
dementsprechend sind wir euch den ganzen
tag hier zählt das kriegt man glaube ich
auch auf youtube mit dass wir uns halt
voll gut verstehen und auch mega gute
freunde und halt nicht nur brüder sind
und dadurch den wir immer hier sebastian
macht hier seine videos das gericht kann
ich sehr gut nachvollziehen aber auch
hier muss ich wieder seine dass das halt
nicht still
übergangsweise nachdem jana uns getrennt
haben tatsächlich aber kurzzeitig schon
okay hier ist ein gerücht hast du mal
betrunken in einem club mit einer um
gemacht hat ich glaube das ist das erste
gerücht dass ich bejahen kann aber ich
glaube auch nicht das ist wirklich ein
gerücht ist ist das so besonders
ich glaube irgendwie nicht aber das
erste gerücht dass ich mit ja
beantworten können auch oft gelesen das
gerücht dass ich eine neue freundin habe
still auch nicht also keine ahnung
die leute das haben wahrscheinlich
denken die sich das ok das ziel dann hat
er mich sah hatte ich aber nicht und das
ist der aktuelle stand
wenn es so wäre würde ich wahrscheinlich
aber auch nicht direkt sagen also es
kommt jetzt hoffen dass ich keine
freundin habe aber wenn ich eine hätte
dann würde ich auch nicht sofort
öffentlich machen weil ich finde so eine
sache braucht auch einfach ihre zeit
man sollte nicht so eine ganz junge
beziehung die noch gar nicht so
gefestigt ist und so was du direkt in
die öffentlichkeit werfen
so haben jana und ich das ja auch
gehandhabt und haben uns erst mal voll
zeit gelassen bevor wir das öffentlich
gemacht haben aber ich habe keine
freunde weiteres gerücht ist dass ich
rauche das habe ich auch bei luca im
video gesehen und genau wie bei lukas
stimmt ist auch bei mir nicht ich bin
auch absoluter nichtraucher und hab auch
in meinem leben glaubt einmal einer
kippe gezogen fast kacke und bin seitdem
entschieden dagegen einfach weil es auch
blöd wäre anzufangen
dementsprechend nein ich brauche nicht
das gericht stellt nicht jammern hier
schreibt eine
gerüchte über mich dass ich also das
mädel ist ein geschickt hat einen 3er
mit dir und deinen bruder welt ok ich
glaube das ist erstens ist kein gerücht
über nicht und zweitens ziemlich komisch
nein hab gehört dass jacko remis und
dieselbe person sind also das ist
natürlich an den haaren herbeigezogen
ich weiß nicht wer der krimi nicht kenne
ich bin es euch jetzt mal hier ein ist
irgendwie so ein typ der so komische
pinke sachen anders immer im video von
sebastian aufgetreten ist
[Musik]
weil damit habe ich überhaupt nichts zu
tun und ich finde es absolut unmöglich
dass leute behaupten dass es mit dem
irgendwas zu nette bitte lasst ein
weiteres gerücht du bist frauen und
letzten videos hoch dass es wieder ein
gerücht das stimmt ich probiere mich zu
bessern aber jetzt mein das sage ich
auch alle drei videos gekippt das
wahrscheinlich mittlerweile im moment
bin ich aber wirklich am überlegen was
kann ich machen was ist irgendwie
aktuell und interessant und ich probiere
auch so ein bisschen nicht so neu zu
erfinden
es kommt auf jeden fall demnächst ein
projekt auf euch zu das wird heftig und
ich sage schon mal so viel es wird mit
kelly kommen
ich glaube das wird richtig richtig
durch die decke gehen und darauf können
wir wirklich wirklich gespannt sein das
kommt bei ich sag mal ich sage nichts
dazu
aber es kommt bald und es wird kraft ihr
freund ich würde sagen dass war es von
den gerüchten über mich zum größten teil
hat einfach nicht gestimmt und wenn sie
gestimmt haben dann waren die relativ
langweilig ich hoffe mal das video ich
trotzdem gefallen und ich würde ihnen
sehen uns beim nächsten video wieder
haut rein macht es gut und keine ahnung
habt ihr euch gefallen stadtteil in die
kommentare da sehen wir uns das war ein
komisches ende
[Musik]